Hey Erin!
Hey Matt!
Good to see ya!
Great to see you!
I thought maybe we would...
Game might be too strong over here,
but we would maybe do a little exercise,
because yeah, if you're not used to
sort of doing the switch and thinking,
knowing what's important to be the same
between your images and somebody else's
workflows images, like what actually
matters versus what doesn't matter,
is not something that probably most people
immediately have intuition about.
Yeah, absolutely.
I certainly didn't.
So again, I thought we might talk
through some examples of like,
how would we figure this out?
I love it.
So let's start with,
is it important that they use the same microscope as me?
No. I say no, not at all.
Yeah.
It might matter in terms of things like
figuring out image loading and stuff,
like your file names might be slightly different,
but otherwise, yeah, really doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Yeah, so that's to say...
I was going to say, I mean, I think for any of these,
it is a good distinction.
Like probably it will make some amount of difference, right?
For any of these, it's like you will,
you are unlikely to take a pipeline that you find
in somebody's repository and just be able to press
go and have it work exactly how you want
on your images, but the amount of,
like how close it will get you and how much work
it will take to get it to work on your,
to handle your images, to work on your images.
I think that's what we're talking about here, right?
So as you mentioned, like same microscope, right?
If you're dropping something in CellProfiler
and it's an ND2 file from one microscope
and a TIFF file from the other,
CellProfiler will load it and run it for you.
You just might have to change one line
in your image import specifications to say,
hey, look at my folder of images.
I have TIFF files, not ND2s, right?
But that's, you know, but that's easy.
You can do that.
You absolutely can.
And I think one that's related to exactly the point
you just made is like the number of channels.
Like if it's something is expecting to split
into four channels as opposed to three,
like it might be, this is sort of in a,
it depends if it's important.
If you only care about one of the channels
that is being used to like measure or find objects
and nothing like you don't,
they have extra channels that you don't need,
then you can totally adopt somebody else's workflow
and just sort of throw those extra channels away.
If it's like, well, they're doing something
where like they identify the Golgi and then some spots
and like they only look for spots inside the Golgi
and you don't have a Golgi marker.
If you're missing channels, that might matter.
It depends how those channels are used in the workflow.
And it's kind of the only thing that you'll know
until you look at it.
But if you don't need, if the channels that they're sort of
using aren't controlling segmentation,
probably it doesn't matter.
It certainly doesn't matter if you don't need
their extra channels.
Yeah.
Yeah. And likewise, you know, any workflow,
but even just in thinking about like the number of channels,
right, importing in your data,
whether it can handle an image stack of three channels
versus an image stack of six channels,
that part, like just the number is likely to be in the,
yeah, don't worry about it.
Because again, like, you know, tiny modifications
to bring the data in.
Yeah.
One thing that, you know, again, just sort of say,
like we will say that some things are important,
like something that's built for white light,
either sort of bright field microscopy or chromogenic stains,
you know, your tissue stains through H&E.
There are certainly ways to adapt workflows like that
to them be fluoresced, to work for fluorescence,
but they're often not simple.
Generally speaking, a lot of software specializes in one
or the other, and its capabilities in the other are not as strong.
Which is not to say it can't be done,
but you will probably have a harder time adapting a workflow
if you have, you know, H&E,
and this is meant for fluorescence or vice versa.
Yeah.
Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
That's definitely a, you know, advanced image analysis task.
Yeah.
But the specifics exactly of, you know,
what, how they're doing it,
not actually really important at all.
What's your late ruling reagent?
Doesn't really matter.
What's your floor for?
Yeah.
So if you are, you know, wanting, wanting to look at the ER, right,
it doesn't matter if somebody has dropped, you know,
dropped a dye in or that's going to stain, you know,
concavalin A and you've just got it accumulating in your ER
and staining all of it.
Or if you've got a protein and antibody to a protein that's in
the ER and so you've like carefully labeled just sex 61
or something and it's there, like if it's labeling the ER,
it's labeling the ER and if you're interested in the ER,
it doesn't matter.
Likewise, if it's, you know, GFP or RFP or whatever,
doesn't, doesn't really matter generally.
Right.
So again, here in the always, it depends if you,
if you are very interested in, like I'm interested in a specific
protein, right?
Or your earlier example, like H2AX, right?
If that is the protein and I am interested in, then actually it
really does matter that somebody's used that exact antibody,
but if it's, you know,
So yeah, but it's, we're not saying for any of these that you
can use somebody's thing without checking that it works in yours.
We're just saying like how easy it's going to be to pour like
don't just assume.
Yeah.
And somebody might, if you study sex 61 and you get something
from somebody who studyes sex 61, that doesn't mean that it will
actually work for your data.
It is none of these things are guaranteed that it will or won't
work.
These are just things that tend to matter versus tend not to.
Yes, absolutely.
When I was a new image analyst, sort of mind boggling to think
that actually even a species doesn't even matter, right?
If I have a workflow for finding spots, right?
Like it could very well be that this workflow set up for spots is
to find gut granules inside of a C elegans nematode the same way
that it's going to find H2A X spots in a human cell to a mirror,
right?
Like what?
What?
That's crazy.
Crazy, but true.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
And so I put the cell light over there too, because yeah, absolutely.
Which is not to say that some like, you know, something that's made
for an adipocyte is going to necessarily work with no tweaks
whatsoever in terms of like a neuron, but we reuse lots of things
for different cancer lines or fibroblast lines and they're
pretty easy to adapt from one to another.
Yeah.
So if we think about, you know, sort of a generic CellProfiler
pipeline that has lots of modules that are measuring lots of
things and lots of channels, and we think about like what would
be different between, again, you said like an adipocyte,
versus, you know, another cell line like he was cells or just
little in brain or neurons, right?
Which can be all projections and weird, right?
So of this entire pipeline, it might actually just end up being
one module that identify secondary objects module that were tuning.
So in this case, it can actually be a lot of aggravation sometimes
tuning that module to get really, you know, if you need really
accurate segmentation and what you're starting from is this
cute little nice round cell and then I'm trying to move into
something with crazy projections or tons of lipid droplets or
whatever, in terms of the overall workflow, right?
Like that's just one module that I'm tuning and the whole rest
of the workflow can remain totally untouched.
Mm-hmm.
Yep, absolutely.
And again, thinking about things in pixel space, like in terms
of difficult of adaptability, you know, we also don't care about,
we don't really care about how big the objects are in sort of
truth, true size, like, because something that is huge and your
hundred X objective, lots of magnification is pretty small
in your 10 X objective.
And so if it's a five pixel size thing, something that's built
to find five pixel size things will probably work.
I even put this only as kind of important because for lots of
things you can change the expected size pretty easily.
It's not undemported, but it's generally not like the hardest
thing to tune.
Yeah.
I mean, especially if we're comparing it to, you know, real
physics, right?
Where we don't care about the real object size at all whatsoever.
Mm-hmm.
Other things that sort of fall into the kind of, for me at
least anyway, and again, this is going to be the ones where
reasonable people may disagree.
The shape, like some things will work really well for dots
versus rods and stuff.
To some degree it depends on if your deep learning tends to be
a little bit better at not caring too much about shape than
classical segmentation.
But so if you're looking at something that's act in filaments,
you might not want to take something that somebody's thing
for finding small round blobs.
Like, they might be pretty different.
Yeah.
Yeah, I probably would have put shape in the super important.
All right, let's do it.
Yeah.
Just because the light source is lonely, it needs a friend.
So we might, you know.
It does.
But again, like, same thing.
Yeah, I would also give it this friend too.
Yeah.
Which is if your things are like beautifully spaced apart or
there's maybe even only one thing, you're probably going to
make a very different pipeline or workflow than like one where
everything is super clustered and you're having to like find
things that are crawling all on top of each other and like
angle them.
That is one of the hardest things to do.
And so if your stuff is super clustered, something that is for
single or well spaced objects will almost certainly not work
for you.
Yeah.
Likewise, if your stuff is super well spaced, somebody who's
made something from clustered might, will probably work for
you, but it might also be doing lots of stuff to force like
separations and force breaking into sub objects, which for you
isn't true and you don't need and actually makes your workflow
worse.
Yeah.
And so one versus many is kind of important, but mostly just
because it might affect this like patterning and you know, if
there's one and you've put in assumptions that say there will
only ever be one.
In cell part, for example, in the filter objects module, you
can say keep only, you know, the biggest thing or the smallest
thing or the brightest thing, but like keep only one.
Yeah.
Which is easy enough to remove, but the assumptions might be
different.
Yeah.
So that's my sorting.
Reasonable people made a disagree.
Sometimes we disagree with ourselves from five minutes ago,
but the biology, like most of the stuff that's in this we don't
care about is actually the biology.
Like we actually don't care about biology very much.
Really what we care about are things in pixel space like are
things light on dark versus dark on bright?
How many pixels across are things and you know, are things
kind of all on top of each other or separated?
Yeah.
This is sort of switching from thinking like a biologist just in
general to thinking like an image analyst, right?
Like this switch of let me think about the analysis task of
the project.
So we're thinking about the task that we're performing here and
having that switch, which is a hard switch to do.
If you're new to image analysis, it really is a different way of
thinking about the problem.